on l'a compris c'est le système des
aveux qui est en cause
patrick dils avait en effet reconnu sa
culpabilité sur procès verbal
mais tout au long de l'audience la
défense a montré qu'on pouvait être
entre guillemets fabriquer les aveux
c'est une question centrale
bonsoir patrick mauduit vous c'est vrai
officier de police les gardes à vue vous
connaissez bien
est ce que vous vous reconnaissez qu'on
peut finalement à l'usure extorqué en
quelque sorte d aveu extorqué des aveux
ne sert strictement à rien il faut
savoir que lors dans une affaire
criminelle
il faut que les déclarations de
l'individu contre lequel pèsent des
éléments à charge doivent ces
déclarations doivent coïncider avec les
constatations qui ont été faites sur
place
constatation extrêmement précises
constatations il s'agit pas simplement
d'eux de décrire complètement et le plus
précisément possible ce qui se passe sur
la scène du crime mais il faut également
montrer le cheminement de l'acte
meurtrier parce que derrière il y à une
instruction qui va absolument tout
reprendre oui donc mettre à disposition
quelqu'un avec des aveux extorqués dans
un dossier mal ficelé
c'est faire se faire complètement capoté
tout le réseau leur de blanquette femmes
et là on voit quand même que les aveux
ont eu un rôle crucial dans les deux
premières condamnations de deal
on a vu aussi qu'ils avaient d'autres
exemples dans le sujet dominique
verdeilhan donc sk pas des cas où des
personnes à vous savez conduit en prison
et on se rend compte finalement qu elles
n'ont pas commis le crime parce que ces
aveux lors on était un peu arraché ou
réécrits écoutez je n'ai jamais eu le le
cas dans dans le cadre de mon expérience
personnelle d'avoir ce cette sorte de
d'erreur vous avez jamais vu des gens à
bout finalement qu'ils sont prêts à
reconnaître un crime qu'ils n'ont pas
commis parce qu'ils sont fatigués et
puis peut-être parce qu'on fait un peu
pression sur eux et non du tout le lieu
de l'audition c'est une technique elle
s'apprend dès l'entrée
dans la police c'est un canevas on
commence par entendre la personne sur
son état civil sur ses ressources
cela permet également d'amorcer un
dialogue et dans des cas extrêmes en
particulier lorsqu il y à des pervers
lorsqu'il y a des des scènes de crimes
abominables donc des assassins
épouvantable cela permet donc d'arriver
à des confidences et je parlerai mois
plus tôt de confidences que d'aveux mais
là comment comment expliquer ce une
confidence mais c'est pas une confidence
visiblement il n'a pas commis le crime
qui lui est reproché et ça a été le cas
aussi pour la faire rebond alors je ne
voudrais pas revenir sur cette affaire
il y a eu trois jugements
donc il a été condamné la première fois
il ya quinze ans il était condamné il y
a quelques mois
et cette fois ci donc au bout de trois
fois et bien le l'avocat général
reconnaît que ça peut être considéré à
de l'acharnement
visiblement doute quoi écoutez je ne je
ne n'ai pas travaillé sur cette affaire
donc il est toujours difficile d'évoquer
un dossier maintenant il y a quinze ans
le policier donc qui a qui a recueilli
ses aveux donc qui coïncidait avec des
quoi ça sert des constatations qui ont
été faites donc des aveux qui était
troublant aveux qu'il a répétée auprès
d'un juge d'instruction
alors que s'est-il passé il n'y a que
patrick dils qui peut le savoir
peut-être nous le dira t-il dans de très
nombreuses années une fois qu'il aura
fait le retour là il est enfermé dans
cette négation des faits maintenant
etait-il sur place de quelle façon se
trouvait-il sur place at il participé
comme on me l'a déjà fait a été assisté
par par des complices où ils étaient ils
caché dans les fourrés
où est il passé quelques secondes après
le départ puisqu'on parle de la présence
de francis heaulme donc est-il passé at
il vu des choses et donc ce qu'il a vu
l'ont fortement imprégné et il
il est donc celui correspondait il a vu
la scène de crime
maintenant à partir de là c'est bien
c'est un gamin de 16 ans oui merci
patrick mauduit merci d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation et vous